two different questions with
simultaneous equations in them and I've
crafted each of them one and two to use
the one two methods that you know for
algebraically dealing with these things
without drawing them if you're involved
so I'm not going to get you guys to come
up because it does actually take your
time does anyone have an idea at least
another line answer of how that approach
number one know anyone you have to get
at least one of the equations to have x
equals 2 or Y years yeah fantastic okay
so we remember the challenging thing
about having some taste equations got a
pair of them but with great
responsibility comes with two equations
you have to solve for two variables and
that's what makes this more challenging
so we're trying to take this problem
which is hard and turn it into an easier
problem yesterday or last week for
review questions I gave you the
equations where there's just one
variable one equation you guys can eat
that for breakfast even when there's
like weird fractions and X's on both
sides
so how do you tell one of these into one
of those you remember I mentioned you've
got a really named these equations you
can't interact with them together unless
you know which one is which once you've
called one one and the other one two I
can operate on them I can do any
operations that I want I want to choose
ones that will do what we did wanted
which is get rid of my I or get rid of
an X so what's something I could do to
equation one and equation two that will
remove that would take away one of the
variables it's a word I'm trying to
avoid that starts with E but I don't say
it because it would kind of spoil it
I'm trying to eliminate one of the
variables so I'm left with just one of
them right looking at the particular
numbers that are there I think we can
eliminate the Y's if we what are we
going to do to both equations can you
see there's a plus 3y here
there's a minus 3y here so if you put
them together the plus 3 right and the
minus 2 I will get an agent that will
happen if I add these together okay so
this will be the first line of working
that I have for question 1 I'm gonna say
1 plus 2 okay is this reading a bit of a
bell when you see that so you take
everything on the left you add it you
take everything on the right and you add
2x plus 5x
the whole reason we tries to add them is
because these guys are just going to
collapse they gone you don't have to
deal with them at all right hand side 5
plus 4 and that's about as
straightforward as you can get I know
what to do with this
I just want X by itself so I will divide
by 7 which gives you the value for X but
there was another proneural to find
right so what am I gonna do yeah so
that's what it C is so I'm going to put
that into one of these do you have a
preference so which one you just won I
would also probably choose the first one
for at least two reasons number one it's
positive
yeah so I will avoid making signs
wherever I can just like I avoid
fractions secondly I just it's a 2
instead of a 5 like I just want to do
smaller numbers around the big ones
because they're easy for my head okay so
I'm going to what's the name when you
put it back into something else I'm
gonna substitute so I'm going to
substitute X into as you suggested
I'm just going to write a letter for
went up except instead of X I'll write
my new number okay the rest of this is
just a little bit of crunch again we
transform the problem which we sort of
icky to deal with into a problem that we
know what cuts in the Librium two times
9 over 7 is 18 while I'm at it I might
as well write is 5 as something over 7
what's 5 is something over 70/7 I think
it's Teddy fine right 35 over 7 you can
just mentally check 35 divided by 7 is 5
why then do you know why don't I decide
to make it missio so that because I see
I already have this fraction over here
right so I kind of want these two to
talk to each other there are 35 mm
bikini I'm gonna take away 18 which
leaves me with bacon 17 17
are you asking about this you got that
why I did that yeah sure and it isn't
intuitive because five wouldn't listen
me why would I bother making it messy
like that and the reason I make it messy
is for the same reason if I wanted you
to evaluate that you would make that
Messier aha plus a third that the simple
service fractions gap but to actually
add them together I think this is more
useful to me right the fractions are
Messier but at least they can talk to
each other which is exactly the scenario
last one what I do I'm just going to
divide both sides by three 17.21
fantastic now I will admit if you got
that outside you looked at it there's a
weird looking numbers did I get it right
oh yeah
the main reason saying we have numbers
is because I just made these up on the
fly usually we would take a bit more
time to craft that so you end up with
neat numbers but there's nothing wrong
with it if you really wanted to don't
check let me take this guy and this guy
and you can substitute them back into
your original equations both of them and
they'll work now just because of the
length of time that way through I'm not
gonna finish solving number two but I'm
gonna give you just the beginning of it
okay this is by elimination you can't do
this by elimination if you want but
there's another way you can do it
there's another technique you have at
your disposal what's it called solving
by substitution okay so he's the layer
would begin we might finish it but it
alone it'll give you start if you're
like I didn't know where to be this is
equation one
can you see the reason why I think don't
worry about eliminations is because
unlike in question one see how these
numbers really nicely match up to each
other it's like someone deliberately did
it so they would match up in question
two there's nothing like that okay all
of the numbers are all mismanaged
okay so therefore I'm gonna look at
equation one and I'm going to rearrange
it and I even write that I'm doing this
you see just like the opening sentence
in a paragraph in an essay you kind of
want to say what you're doing so they
know what on earth you're talking about
so I'm going to say alright this algebra
I'm going to begin this is what I'm
going to do with it
this equation here I'm going to make a
the subject it's not hard to make a the
subject what would I do to both sides so
I already have a minus to these so I
will add to me and that'll get it over
to the other side so I'm going to get N
equals two and you came with that okay
so I'm gonna take this guy and as the
name suggests I'm going to substitute
into my other equation you can rename
this if you do do you remember I said
don't just name it randomly you could
name the equation three but I'm actually
gonna call it 1a so that I don't mistake
the equation three doesn't tell you
where it came from but 1a says where you
came from one do you remember what
happens if you accidentally take an
equation and substitute it back into
where it came from because they don't
remember
let me I'm direct this down because it's
confusing but let me show you right if I
take this it came from one let me just
put it back into one see what happens
instead of a I'm going to write this so
there's the a take away two B equals
seven and you're like oh cool I'm really
good at collecting like terms and you're
like okay that's great I mean it's yeah
it's not wrong but it hasn't gotten you
anywhere so that's why if you say where
it came from that's kind of useful
information don't put it back in to
where it came from
even though 77 which is really put it
into the other equation so I like that
this is where the method gets its name
from so I'm going to have six lots of
that one and then I'm just gonna go
ahead and stall I don't think we need to
finish that now it's the same kind of
Steel that you were working on here but
you can have a guard if you want to
check when you got the right answer and
I'll just call me at the lab okay